i want to earn my seat at the table you
know and that's why i started doing
standard because there's a certain
stigma about oh if you're a ig community
you can't do stand-up or you like you
don't deserve a seat you know i'm like
at this table stand-up comedians look
down on people who do ig comedy yeah i
mean i've had standard comedians tell me
like you ain't it yeah yeah you know so
now you're doing standing not in a bad
way yeah and then so i said [ __ ] it all
right cool i need to earn my seat i'm
gonna earn my seat and this is even when
i already had george lopez hit me up and
be like yo
i see you keep doing your thing like
your next type of [ __ ] and then i've had
other comedians hit me up like you know
uh you know felipe esparza has been
really supportive you know what i'm
saying uh you know troll fake creeper
has been really supportive you know
these are all guys that do stand up
um you know jerry garcia you know which
you know gave me an opportunity to do
the you know uh toho los toxicos tour
with them so it was jingle bling and his
mat
his maga routine yeah
because who's the comedian all these
guys have been like
that have been in the industry for you
know that between all of them they got a
hundred plus years of experience at
stand up to tell me like yo pursue this
[ __ ] this is this is this is where you
need to be
then it was kind of like all right
because i was fighting standards i'll
say how's the stand-up thing because
that's a hard thing to get into man it's
not the same obviously i mean it's
yeah i mean it's not the same right
you know uh luckily for me i come from a
rapper's lane so you're not scared to be
on stage so i'm scared to be on stage
and command attention and do crowd work
and do all that [ __ ] right so i've been
there before now i was just implementing
something and you've hosted the tours
and [ __ ] that's kind of like for sure
yeah yeah yeah you know i mean it's you
know from doing i mean you know like
people tell me like dawg like you should
be able to handle this you know 300 play
uh you know 300 person crowd at the
laugh factory
and i try to tell them like it's
different having 17 000 people that half
of them are not even paying attention to
you yeah because there's just so much
[ __ ] going on a lot of drunk people to
300 people right in front of you and
they're like harder and they're all
harder
you know but yeah and then like come on
entertain us make me laugh more you're
like yeah yeah you know like it's time
let's go i pay 25 and let's get it
but nah dude it's it's been really good
um you know uh according to my peers and
the people that have been there like yo
like you're killing it so so it's been
cool man